たいうわけで南部ぞに来ました
鍵付きもついてきてるんですけども影響の
動画なってと言えば山で虫取りじゃない
ですか山に6一人しても捕まえれるリオた
ぬかせてるんで今日は来ればを利用して服
が見つかってか蓋はしない捕まえろー
[音楽]
here もちろん
here から have lost れ
そうなポットに後輩の
黒瀬私 come here なってさ
安全たくさん準備してきましたで株主や
公正なんで一晩置いてまた帰ったときに
これはに株トムスが何昼のか見ていきたい
とおもいます結構つかまると思うけど作る
ちょっと寄っタイミングでどんな用意して
くるパパで行ってきます
woman 広げてくださいねそれから
これパイプみたいなやつってくださいん
スパショカードは黒日本
アゲアイエーゼットハイになる
web
ござい何か
[音楽]
follow 便良本部ましたなぁ
採用の復帰かけてください
さあ何も聞いてくださっはーいもう
ナナちゃんそろそろコロネいうことか
俺を持った
まずから揚げ屋私を撮りましたん
ううっで大胆とも未だですん
彼ママというわけでようやく上げと
キャンプ場に放置して車だけを奪って
外そう虫がいそうな山のスポットに置く
ことができましたあーこれですねなぜこの
ようなことができパ
ドゥ本日アシスタントあーヌーですキョロ
さん小古曽やばいよね静岡に少ないさんの
山があって発言している on 8倍に
かけでございます放置できるっていうか
マジですできないことだなぁファッション
とじゃあありがとうございますまたござい
ます続けて今回改めて説明いたしますと
はじめんですね夏の思い出に花葡萄もし
タッカーん捕まえたい
たっくん使いたいのでカウントん薄い
捕まえているグッズたくさん準備しました
すごい敗2分けで早速何を以ってきたら
紹介しましょうちなみに結構いろいろ考え
て持ってきました今回まずはこちら白い
ネットです
白いネット虫ってそもそもで捕まるところ
がないとその場にとどまらないのでくれ
まって結果で貸せるんです金属棒 p なん
でカブトムシが来ても止まることができ
ないんで終わるために虫の爪切っ書くと
取れなくなるんじゃないかぐらいの細かい
網をズームしましたこれはず車にかぶせて
行きたいと思いますそれでは行きます俺
でかいと思うんだけっこうこれソーの音が
入ってるぞ
いやー完璧完備9トンテキ2行政株と走っ
てしっかりに集まるはないんでしたけど
あくまでが集まります壁と走って光に
集まるんでこちら準備しました
白い布でございます白い物ってひっかりを
反射するんで光やてるとめっちゃ光るん
ですよこれで虫が反応してめっちゃ臭よっ
てくるはずです
zumba 逆だったら
あー
ぬーっのパーいますちょっとああああ
ヌーましたはいというわけでこんなと一つ
らしっかけを仕掛けていきますまずは機
カブトムシ機あったらくる切ないとかあり
ます好きで清水ってジュルジュしたいです
ね
なあコレでしょああああああっはぁ
nice
さあ皆さんここからが仕掛けの時間です
まずはこちら塗り小銭
1.5キロ分ですもう絶対コレカブトムシ
包んで100%
これどういう効果があると昆虫が好むと
いわれるライダーフレーバーと分かりませ
んそれとこれマジで株と4月10日に
それぞれ車にぶっかけていきますよぞ
頑張るわ
うっはっ
はー
えっはっはースッといいです
ね
これめっちゃケバブやメス多分あっ
あと35あるんですよ
いや2分じゃないった結構打って車か見た
目です甘いたベルトです2人暮らし
あっはいこれがサブ飛ばしよってくる
らしいですよ
アラサー続いての仕掛けで続いてはこちら
昆虫ジェリー20個でございます今何が
すごいかといいますと食べやすいんです
それは宮田人間も昆虫を食べやすいに越し
たことないんで aveda て今
ちょっとでも20個を配置していきたいと
おもいます
バッハ
あっ
すごい
ホッ
マッハ
づらそうです
あったさあかなりすごいことになってき
ました某何が起きたのか何人な人を轢いて
しまったのか
ます
そして最後はコチラで
家で作ってきました特製のトラップ行き
です midi あるどうぞでは早速特製
のトラップを作っていきましょう必要な
もの版の焼酎を佐藤以上ですまず便に招致
を入れますアルコールすごい一強いな
[音楽]
ん
濡れたショーツに砂糖入りできますこぼす
とまた首2コースてゴキブリくるこぼす
ゴキブリきちゃう
ああああああ
すげーてから入れてる are you
doing にするっ
きもへ
[音楽]
a
疑問希望1親おいしい蔵王地蔵寺とだけど
いい
[音楽]
ガチで黒いで最後に花に砂糖を刷り込ま
せるために中で組んで腕します
あああああ
すごいって3曲結構やばいうわああああ
[音楽]
ua
逆に今日チーム a もう
はいないの
もういいんじゃないでしょうかはい風はい
これマジでカブトムシが寄ってきて止まん
なくなるらしいんですよぶっかけましょう
作った時と比べてかなり色がヤバイんです
けどこれがなんかカブトムシ的に言い出す
んでちょっと発行したくないが
スーツでかけません
なあこれダネッ
[音楽]
の売買も本当にごめん源助かぶどうすると
ねぇねぇもう一発駅前
[音楽]
ん
ああああああっ
これはすぐいい
マッチョ
はいっ
me
[音楽]
meというわけでこの車でテーマ佐藤瑞
バナーな少数株主ゼリーとしが来る
ドリンクみたい熱としてきそうなキー後
白い布をつかまれるネットがブッ通してが
好きなものを全て網羅させていただきまし
たもう本当にありがとうございますよ
まったくずっきゅん県詰まっでも県警
カブトムシとかクワガタ方知った方
一応本人の願い通りにはなってるかな友達
買ってあげてだいたいですね半日ぐらい
おくと家が集まれて言われていると以前ん
私朝には論だけハブと走っクワガタいるの
でしょうかはいという訳 j ライトも
大抵カメラも放置して朝まで待ちます電池
切れるまでとっておきます
帰ります目ばいっす
[音楽]
ん
me
meme
[音楽]
ねっ
me
2x
ええええええええええええ
[音楽]
me
おっ
[音楽]
うわぁさあ
はパッソをダレって誰も死ぬんじゃないな
音です
[音楽]
散歩商材はそのん
パソ散歩松月 s 依存症でしょうね
それでまーす懸垂さ昨日からていうかだと
思っ車3でなくない横暴指導も組手たです
ね車ねぇちょっと移動しちゃってるよ
犬ってさクワガタなんか pos みたい
なこと言ってなかったどうかと思う
南に入ったつつへ行ったらいいですね
捕まえたいが判書パパ ok って受け
野党で使えるようないんだけど僕に変える
ようなや兜は羽生とも言えばまあ
老いたるももしかそれかいたなってる死ぬ
んですねまぶし君できるかなっていう虫
キングできるかなその1がケースになるん
だったら俺まぁ良かったかなぁかを設け
レゲエ好きな僕もなんですけど
ほとばし欲しいなと思って大きな俺
しばらくいなかった者長い時間いなかった
ですね
こちらご覧くださいどうぞ
[音楽]
なになになになにやに何車だけど何これな
に乗ってるこれうんこ
えっ
うっころって何か
なにこれ
マジで何コレ
えっ
何孤児ミク
颯也う切ったの下へ行っちゃうねこれ件
ゲー
何カブトムシクワガタを捕まえるゼリーと
はだねーよ卵ですよ
パック
[音楽]
うっうー
どぅいませんぬーラングラー
am どう見て絶対願ってそのつもりで来
たーこっちを抜けるな5敗の車をフルに
活用してカブトムシケ峯各ラップをつくっ
てみたんですけども
一匹起きませんでした
ua
んっ
あのムンナム杏皆さんあの本当に可哀想
って言わないで下さいの権氏は技術科って
ちょっと曲はえって私やっておりますので
全然スペースなんですよやっぱほんと
クワガッタンが欲しい買うと欲しいんじゃ
なかご支援でを誓ったすべてが理にかなっ
て私全力だめだワン食べたがもうちょっと
見たかったけどいないなっていう印象を
受けます全然-8ないやんけ唯一一人お客
さんの様子今そこにいらっしゃいますね
こちらですねいらっしゃいますね奴とまた
来年リベンジまずは今シーズンもうこれら
ふとチャンス見たかったから雷鳴はずれ
ますよそうかわかったどんなトークなまた
件数に内緒でお会いしましょうって
マッシャーて